previously on TV since we are going to
blow her up we will feature her online
and in the paper but we need images that
photo gets a job
what do you wait for Chinese New Year
spaceships future war London England was
it just me or does this show already
have a region Big Ben sighs Doctor Who
Bunner Vandal Savage an evil dictator
blessed with immortality DC CW can't
stop with the endless also Vandal Savage
geez DZ you could name a villain more on
the nose if you try why not just name
him bad guy evil sin and be done with it
he has achieved what no one in human
history ever has he has conquered the
entire planet someone might be able to
trump that statement in a few years you
take after your mother huh or not most
people don't remember but for a short
time in 2016 the CW changed their
tagline from dare to defy - we kill kids
on our shows cBS compared to Savage his
forces have already trained in the time
masters Council rip hunter is proving
that he's the master debater as a time
master of long standing you seem to
forget our responsibility is to protect
the timeline not humanity I've been the
only way to protect the timeline is to
not travel through time right so then
why was time travel ever invented and
why was a time masters Council ever
needed time travel storylines and how
they make you question every goddamn
thing that happens just going to go
ahead and add 10 sins for all the
time-travel snafus that will [ __ ]
happen all throughout this show also
discount Rory is talking about a Time
Master like a lord over time like a Time
Lord so to speak but they have three
lungs and travel in a sentient spaceship
called a Dardis cuz the early second
millennium ad the Golden Age of gasoline
engines online pornography and those
silly little smartphones and fidgets
spinners
you forgot fitted spinners the eight men
and women who'll be joining us on our
little crusade and I conveniently have
exactly eight years behind me where they
can sit even though I usually have no
need for them because I usually work
alone first recruit dr. Raymond Palmer
also known as the Atem oh crap this is a
putting the team together episode isn't
it you know sometimes I feel like if TV
wanted to make me a chocolate chip
cookie they couldn't do it without
telling me the origin story of flour and
butter how the two ingredients first got
to know each other and then vanilla
drops in like oh hey guys and all this
time I'm in the corner with my glass of
milk wanting to just eat a cookie
already where's my cookie show where's
my freaking cookie it's just good things
back in the fields of course celebrating
a transition from Superman to discount
ant-man kind of feels like a bit of a
downgrade the only way you could have a
more drastic drop on the superhero
spectrum as if you went from Marvel to
DC where you up for this there are so
many goddamn arrow cameos on these shows
at this point I assume Stephen Amell
just sleeps in that suit I know I do I
mean oh I am NOT one of your adversaries
I am stupid enough to stand right behind
you and catch you by surprise while you
have your arm gun locked and loaded miss
Lance join me for a drink how exactly is
hunter overtaking these people you
telling me Sara can't avoid being shot
is the British accent his power is it
really that charming yes yes I know it
is firestorm the merged super form of
one jefferson jackson and professor
martin stein and originally from the
show with the flash apparently in fact
everyone on this team feels like some
sort of cast off from a different show
the show is basically the CW version of
summer camp Friday night casserole I
mean we got these leftovers we might as
well use them up somewhere I get that
rip has a bigger agenda than just
stopping a petty criminal but there was
a person that Jefferson and Martin just
apprehended that I'm assuming just got
left there once rip used his little
laser gun on them what if he grows up to
be a super criminal even worse than
Vandal Savage this is exactly what the
time masters were concerned about the
first place rip cops'll never hassle a
dad buying diapers in the middle of the
night watching teen Prison Break here do
a cheap Raising Arizona imitation and
I'm left wondering is this show
self-aware does it know how over-the-top
Cheesecake Factory it's being is it just
embracing it doesn't even matter for
sitting purposes the answers here in
order who cares
did you say Cheesecake Factory like it
matters and he'll not watch it how
exactly this rips men and black zapper
work does it make whoever he's aiming it
out along with himself disappeared
because either he just got hit by that
van or he caused the cop car behind it
to hit the van and possibly kill
innocent police officers Vandal Savage
that can't be we destroyed him yeah the
green arrow and flash help us do it and
just like that legends indicates that it
will be comprised of 34% expositional
homework from other shows and you know
how we feel about that round here you
got the wrong guy
hero ain't on my resume and apparently
neither is the ability to deliver lines
like an actual human being where when
I'm from the Year 2166 you everyone in
this roof aren't just considered heroes
your legends roll commercials of all the
people who ever lived I chose you eight
and what's very convenient for me is you
I lived at the same time in 2016 so I
wouldn't have to go through millions of
years of history to find a proper team
you're on sir yes maybe this address in
six hours I don't have any other cards
to give these seven other people here
and I'm not sure I've been very clear on
whether I need all eight of you for this
to proceed but I'm sure it'll all work
out
I died once at least the world thought I
did nowhere near the same thing this is
a best chance to stop them forever
better than when you had the green arrow
and the flash assisting you you have a
lot more faith in Prison Break
I did a Living Dead and the Wonder Twins
than anyone else does when it gets to
decide little lady is this closed in
room really the place to go on scuffle
Oh Wild Wings exactly how do those giant
things help in close-quarter it
hand-to-hand combat and now these two
are fighting near high-end computers the
arrowverse heroes not have any training
facilities oh I died if you didn't catch
this from the other 57 times it was
mentioned in the first 12 minutes over
this pilot Sara died can we move on the
Lazarus Pit brought me back but it left
me with this need to take the amount of
exposition and cameo in the setup to the
show is breathtaking like seriously I'm
having trouble maintaining a desire to
keep reading I found it and becoming the
Black Canary for me being the canary was
never that positive then don't be the
canary be the white canary you know when
you say canary that many times in a row
I'm pretty sure it's supposed to mean
something to me but no just another
reference from a different show that
you've given zero context for it's like
trying to read an article where every
other sentence is in a different
language there a Google Translate for
the arrowverse also this is dialogue
that someone wrote and then two people
said it out loud and then a roomful of
people said yeah that's a bunch right
there where's the moon
you don't need it anymore we've lived in
the shadows long enough but that's not
the reason superheroes wear eye masks
it's to protect themselves and more
importantly their family and friends you
100% need a [ __ ] mask not yourself
out you took the words right out of my
mouth oh so I see the parry it's a fire
team here just took their relationship
to the Rufi kidnapping stage isn't that
cute so you're telling me that this card
had an address on it
this is the middle of nowhere in a city
did the card have an actual address or
did it say meet me in the abandoned
parking lot where that serial killer
stashed his bodies that one time shall
we
Episode takes 17 minutes to officially
legends of tomorrow I have never seen
anything like this before neither have I
and considering our 4000 years worth of
memories that seems something but you
haven't been into the future or space so
why is this surprising at all not even
Gideon can determine where or when we
can find it but I have the next best
thing the man who can so Vandal Savage
has covered his tracks enough through
time and not even Gideon can find him
but this [ __ ] cam what exactly does
this guy research that Gideon can't rip
was concerned enough about disrupting
the timeline to have that ship cloaked
while it was on the ground the taking
off and a giant time ship in broad
daylight is perfectly kosher whoa that
is serious yeah we all remember the
Darth Vader who was decked in a silver
metal suit and carried a big gun around
I think that was in the Star Wars what
if everything would be useless in dumb
trilogy that came out in 1985 I'm
determining whether you are integral to
the timeline you are not a man haven't
you ever read a sound of thunder or
watched It's a Wonderful Life the
minimal impact of these guys being gone
from the world could translate into huge
differences that nothing can calculate
why bother 4,000 years ago Vandal Savage
was an Egyptian priest secretly in love
with the priestess professor exposition
rather you and your first life but you
were in love with another and I stepped
into a recording booth for this very
part of the story because gravitas
savage or hath-set as he was then known
learned the affair and was consumed with
jealous rage this ancient Egyptian
backstory is so paint-by-numbers I swear
both Brendan Fraser and Tom Cruise are
about to walk around the corner my
theory is that the three of you were
exposed to the same radiation
meteorites while being bit by a spider
that took Super Soldier Serum and was
struck by lightning you taught me to be
careful keep moving always one step
ahead of savage so you become the
world's leading expert on him to keep
him off your radar we hope you can tell
us a bit more where to locate savages
present whereabouts cool because I just
so happen to have a slide show I'll set
up right here that answers that exact
question more the world is focused on
destroying itself the less it notices an
immortal psychopath sadly this checks
out something tells me you know let's
locate Vandal Savage I have an educated
guess since that's the actual answer to
the original question he asked how about
you leave with that next time buddy we
wants to listen to some captain and
Tennille my mother played it a lot and
apparently jukeboxes in 1975 didn't cost
any money you want to dance Leonard you
go right ahead I'll watch that sounded a
lot creepier than he probably intended
will you join me in the parking lot
because these characters aren't doing
anything that matters the show puts them
in a situation where for no reason that
is clear this [ __ ] starts samsara so
that we can see what a badass he is even
as far back as the 70s random bar
patrons suffered from the incurable
fighting disease of one of the tightest
his name is Chronos he's a temporal
bounty hunter Chronos to parole bounty
hunter I've spent years studying the
implications of chronological alteration
good for you we're not going anywhere
and the system's coming with us I do
what I want routine I'm sure to work on
a Time Master who understands the
severity of time altering decisions
laser cut well jeez was Gideon born in a
futuristic barn how did I leave the door
open when you're under attack where the
hell did the Hawks keep their gear while
they were wandering around the
University we go out for one lousy drink
and you guys somehow managed to pick a
fight with Boba Fett we'll handle the
cheesy outdated cultural references
around here Stone Cold Steve Austin my
son is hurt because of you
damn you went all in on being a mother
despite completely losing that memory
and being reminded of it just an hour
ago
how do you even process something like
that to become super mom in an instant
and your son is like old now
I chose Yule because a hundred years
from now your lives have a minimal
effect on the recorded timeline so I
guess that rules out the idea of the
butterfly effect then suck it Kuchar
just a collection of nobodies who time
really doesn't give a damn about wow
that's harsh but yeah pretty much still
though no worries you have to
to three other shows on the CW scheduled
and they aren't exactly overrun with
quality programs so you should be good
we had a child Jonas legends of tomorrow
flashback tomorrow back I think we all
need a little time to consider our
options but considering there's
obviously in Episode two and three so on
dramatic tension such as this is
pointless they're obviously going to
stay and this serves neither the purpose
of a cliffhanger or an interesting
moment in any way if I don't want to go
home yet
I mean by the change of heart because
the writers room somehow found it
believable that the guy who was
literally drugged and kidnapped would
change his mind even though it appears
even more dangerous and stupid then when
he was protesting in the first place
seems about right the best feeling that
I ever got from being on the field
wasn't when I made a great play all we
want some game was when one of my
teammates took a tackle for me one of
your teammates took a tackle for you
kind of defense was the other [ __ ]
team playing sounds like a description
of football by someone who's never
played it or watched it and there has
been another unfortunate consequence of
Cronos his attack get hear about it oh
really yeah it's probably not important
I don't even know why Gideon is giving
rip a choice to hear this bad news other
than it's because the screenwriter said
so Chronos even vandal bomba the only on
the movie face because God knows how
many episodes we don't have to fill with
this nonsense
you know malcontents I like killing
people Moran I give at least 20 cents
back if Viola Davis showed up right now
eating steak I've already had to give um
lots of cool skip
I'm known to be quite flexing I'm just
forewarning you Marcus what a rotten
name
he had yellow eyes so help me God yellow
eyes what's your name son you that's my
name I bet it uses ionic propulsion I
doubt that very much given that even
advanced technology wouldn't be able to
sustain an ionic reaction not a lot I
found it in becoming a black canary
pretty bird
yeah can you say pretty bird the time
masters discourage marriage I have a
message and a question a message from
the doctor and a question from me where
is my wife